l'actualité du spectacle et plus
particulièrement de la musique rock il y
a dix huit ans mourait le célèbre
guitariste américain jimi hendrix qui a
marqué la de l'essence de toute une
génération
la 5 a réussi l'exploit de retrouver son
père james hendrix qui vit à seattle sur
la côte ouest les états unis il ya deux
célébrités là bas la firme boeing les
avions et la famille hendrix patrick
vilar et qu'ils étaient donc à seattle
avec ahmed seul
souvent imité jamais égalé
jimi hendrix sans doute le plus grand
guitariste de toute l'histoire du rock
disparu tragiquement à 28 ans au sommet
de sa gloire
cinq albums seulement pour révolutionner
un instrument créé une technique et un
sombre qui font encore rêver aujourd'hui
on vérité mon fils qui était sur écoute
fo bouillon sur scène et l apparent qui
joue est une espèce de personnages des
centaines de guitaristes ont voulu un
jour limité par exemple jouer avec leurs
dents mais jim hendry et reste unique
avec sa façon de jouer
bon ben si extraordinaire
110 que m'a beaucoup surpris j'adorais
le blues et la musique de jimmy s'est
véritablement autre chose il était
vraiment très en avance sur son temps
bien devenir d'ailleurs cédé sans doute
d'extrader règne
n'a peut-être pas tort papa hendrix car
depuis on a vraiment rien fait de mieux